many people when they think about
computer crime they think either of a 17
year old kid in his mom's basement kind
of like the Matthew Broderick and that
movie wargames
or they think about Russian organized
crime Eastern European organized crime
but the fact of the matter is is that
not only are criminals early adopters of
technology but so are terrorists
terrorists have been using technology
for years if we go back to the first
World Trade Center bombing that occurred
in 1993 ramzi yousef in 1993 was using a
laptop and the information on his laptop
was encrypted in 1993 when the FBI
seized him and his laptop they couldn't
read the information and had to send it
off to the NSA and it took them a year
to break the crypto on that laptop so
this is not a new phenomenon fast
forward to today criminals are using all
forms of technologies as our terrace
we've seen terrorists use the internet
for a variety of purposes I worked with
the United Nations counterterrorism
implementation task force and on that my
role was to study how terrorists are
using the Internet
and we saw that terrorists use the
internet for fundraising right we see
that they use it for operational
planning they use it for propaganda as
we see with all of these beheading
videos that they put out there they're
using it for recruitment so they have
been doing this for years and years and
years and unfortunately are quite
masterful at it we've seen terrorists
use technology as an integral part of
their attacks the 2008 air attack on
Mumbai which in my opinion has been the
most technologically advanced terrorist
attack to date not only did those
terrorists from an organization called
lucky a toy ba based in Pakistan
come into the city of Mumbai with ak-47s
and RDX explosives and Chinese hand
grenades and the like but they also had
BlackBerry's smart phones satellite
phones night-vision got night-vision
goggles and the like and when they
landed they had one other invention that
the world had never seen before the
establishment of a terrorist operation
center across the border in Pakistan
there the terrorist commanders monitored
the news for example CNN Fox al Jazeera
I
in real-time to see what the news media
was reporting and they also monitored
the internet and on several occasions
throughout the attack we saw the
terrorists see something on BBC for
example BBC reported that the terrorists
were for example in room 315 the terrace
top centre said hey they were putting
urine 315 and the terrorists are having
a conversation
do you see any cameras if you do shoot
them out
so the terrorists through this OP Center
technological Operations Center the type
of stuff that we see on television shows
like homeland in 24 the terrorists built
one of those back in 2008 and were able
to operationalize technological
information in real time
the biggest example of this that I've
cited and talked about this in my TED
talk was a businessman at the Taj Mahal
hotel he was staying in a top floor
suite of the hotel and the terrorists
were going room to room trying to find
additional victims they broke into his
room and they said who are you and what
are you doing here and he said oh I'm
nobody I'm just an innocent
schoolteacher and the terrorists were
dumb but they weren't that dumb they
know that Indian school teachers don't
stay in Suites at the Taj Mahal Hotel
and they found his identification on the
bed next to him they got his name and
they phoned it into their terrorist
operations center the terrorists did
some google searching and came up with a
photograph and then asked the terrorists
on the ground you know your hostage is
he heavyset bald in front is he wearing
glasses yes that's the guy we found him
what should we do and moments later came
the notice from the terrorist commanders
kill him see we worry about our privacy
on Facebook but it turns out even a
simple Google search to a terrorist can
determine who shall live and who shall
die terrorists can use these tools our
openness against us now of course that's
a Black Swan event and we don't want to
exaggerate it but in that case it did
make a difference and because of the
technological edge that the terrorists
had over the police of Mumbai their
ability to escape and monitor the
movements of the Indian National Police
and the Mumbai police that terrorist
hostage siege lasted not one day not to
date but almost three days
of people were killed and hundreds more
were gravely wounded that day men women
and children lost their lives so teres
are adapt at using all of these tools
we've had a case a few years ago in
Boston where a student by the name of
res one furnace at Northeastern
University bought some drones a bunch of
small-scale robotic jets that are 120th
scale and can fly at nearly jet speeds
they have jet engines and his plot was
to load them up with explosives and fly
one into the Pentagon and one into the
Capitol building and he had purchased
the explosives he had purchased a bunch
of ak-47s
he had purchased and assembled these
jets that he was going to remotely
control fly with explosives into
government buildings so it was only
through an FBI informant that this plot
was disrupted so terrorists are using
drones terrorists are using the Internet
they're using smart phones and of course
they're using encryption we've seen them
use tools like telegram and even their
own home-built technological tools we've
seen terrorists and the Taliban for
example it not only fly their own drones
but we've seen them hack the drones of
the United States governments and
intercept their video feeds that they're
over flying Iraq and Afghanistan so Isis
and al-qaeda are quite keen on
recruiting new members with scientific
and technological backgrounds